après les touchés par le génie il est
conduit par laser une fender que donner
naissance à la plus haute vérité c'est
par centaines
on compte invention dans tous les
domaines de la science sont sentis de
fausses d'hypothèses
après plus de 35 ans en recherche et en
innovation et en relisant récemment la
biographie de magellan et mathieu prend
tout seul et s'est fait soigner
je me suis dit que cette hypothèse était
particulièrement ray et avaient été
malades de tous les temps à commencer
par le début de retrait jusqu'à
aujourd'hui au foot
la moitié des migraines défaite sur les
deux ministres ont été faites par hasard
je voudrais vous en donniez quelques
jeunes jeu tous les besoins des
centaines novice défense veille je
commençais à l'examen le premier siècle
de notre ère avec tollé qui définit un
système géocentrique où la terre est au
milieu de l'hiver elles toutes les
planètes qui tournent le modèle
complètement fou mais les hypothèses
tellement tordu que le modèle est
excessivement
précis et les tel manque ici qu'il est
banal jusqu'à 1500 2000 1500 qu'à
l'époque de magellan et même qu'aux
critiques et dès qu'ils perdent entre
mode et vous senti le soleil au milieu
du système solaire le système de blé
mais pour 50 années suivant le niveau
est meilleur au niveau de la
modélisation s'entend dans notre reine
actuelle on considère l un des modèles
on arrive à des résultats de recherche
basés sur des hypothèses chose je ne
parlerai pas de christophe colomb
découvre un continent qui n'est qu'un en
cherchant des uns deviennent beaucoup
d'autres exemples je le pourrai pas y
est logée dans la folle of plein de
listes nicolas capelle un expert de plus
incroyables les années 1500 faire le
tour du monde en hypotenseurs
l'hypothèse que la terre était ronde
en faisant l'hypothèse que les quelques
cas que l'on avait l'année déconner à
l'obésité touche pause en se basant sur
le mouvement des planètes quitté qui
datait toujours et les codes politiques
et des chevaux en accumulant les élans
de la médiation ils sont partis à trois
navires 500 personnes sont brûlés un
avis divergent 10 mégabits cher de
l'autre du monde sur base d'une
accumulation incroyable d'erreur et de
fausses hypothèses
en fait ces éleveurs son duo de feu la
recherche et l'innovation sont durs
beaucoup de paramètres que nous pourrons
pas toujours
de nos jours on essaye de les contrôler
de plus en plus aiguisée au point je
crois que les gens mélangent mais aussi
la l'innovation la gauche donc je vois
quand les journaux invention craché une
innovation cette dame nous avons rejoint
sans imagination créativité au fond
l'écosystème de la recherche tourne
autour de plusieurs mots clés et je
crois qu'il faut construire cet
écosystème open innovation et les
chances de réussir et dans cette chaîne
de cet écosystème le droit à l'erreur
devrait continuer à exister et vous
allez voir que on enquête du ap le
secret on voudrait donner dernières
années le premier paramètre c'est
l'imagination et je crois que tout le
monde à la salle ici ou même un enfant
de 1 an est capable d'imaginer et
l'imagination
si vous tes parents enfants de 2 ans le
week-end prochain jeu pour aller
ensemble sur la plage
il va passer de quelques lignes des
aides sont en vacances à la plage à se
construire de grands ch
dolist un cerf-volant toute
l'imagination d'un monde et le palio
mourir et de laisser son imagination
c'est ce qu'a fait pas gênant quand
island sinon cette aventure on tout dire
on en a mis donc tout le monde est à
venir
deuxième étape c'est la créativité
elle suit directement à l'imagination le
même petit enfant le losc los boys ou
anglaise voulu donner un petit seau en
plastique une balle en plastique
il valait que 22 d'essayer de projeter
son imagination
ce qui est son petit château évidemment
il sera beaucoup plus intime qui avait
suivi la keynote apple mais il m'a même
créé il est dans un processus créatif
il ne faut pas être un scientifique a
une très grande expérience conjointe
pour être créatif nous sommes tous car
il l'a comme troisième mot clé
l'invention mêmes enfants de petite
enfance la salle peut être créatif et
peu inventé par exemple 20 35 le système
où se sont chacun puisse devenir un jour
où il va trouver une prière du matin
tente de persuader son château les tout
il va inventer à gros c'est sur ce donc
de nouveau vous reprendre un chercheur à
venir avec des inventions et le basque
et moqueries et le moulin importante sur
laquelle l'impact sur la société c'est
le conte innovation l'iphone reste à
connaît un peu plus son exemple est
supposé que l'enfant a dit pas retourner
chez lui et on dirait sceptique
allemagne
tu sais beaucoup de le château de 5,6 du
fils mme 1,1 sous une belle et la
cuillère et un petit lac
luciani matin
innovation c'est quelqu'un qui va aller
au delà de la dimension et un cric une
chose où l'on veut montrer que cinq
matches et ça va avoir un impact
important sur le long terme sur la
société
trois mois un pack long terme société
sinon ce n'est pas une innovation
si on revient en bureau d'ingénieurs
comme innovation vous voulez penser
tomassi dix hommes en plus l'été un bel
de téléphone lorsqu'ils ont vu les geeks
tous les deux ont dû tout cela mes
freins sont terminés voilà près la vie
ils ont dit je vous ai montré x10
faisane gelé vous pouvez le ventre
maintenant à vous de génération jument à
l'améliorer à le rendre moins cher alors
en plus facile à utiliser alors rendre
plus beau etc et on sort un tout petit
peu de l'innovation c'est une
amélioration de miniatures mais ce n'est
plus qu'une hâte c'est de l'amélioration
alors je faisais beaucoup parler d'eux
du azem et les élus qui veulent
reconduire la découverte au niveau ils
viennent par centaines
maintenant je voudrais prendre un peu un
regard différent et vous montrer que le
laser aussi où les erreurs peuvent
conduire à des membres de dépôt lui vous
propose des allemandes de chambre qui
fait que nous découdre est pas quelque
chose comme ça et tous les animaux au
paiement un mage elland jamais rien il
est le bouquin sur les 500 m kazan et où
les ingénieurs avaient toutes les
données en main ou de lino
et ont raté le coche simplement à cause
d'une position
l'état d'esprit je vais me permet de
prendre un exemple j'ai bien lu
passionnément
si j'ai commencé ma carrière chez
philips vous avez tous ont connu le
cellulaire dix semaines de philips 1989
c'est sans doute la dernière innovation
de fusent visiblement 1780 vous avez
tous connu le four un problème il
connaissait les 6 et 10 les vidéos
qu'ils le vcl sert à tous ces enfants je
lis tout jouer ma musique jouée vidéo
ils ont raté l'arrivée des mémoires dont
sydney est alors que j'avais sur mon
temps de jeu se joue à peu près 1 md
francs c'est de la musique connaît on
n'a pas développé
il a fait de la trempe 1998 disant
au plus société coréenne et
l'idée de mettre de la musique sera
supporter at il à l'époque
des sociétés comme sony thompson et
julie ce pas mal d'esprits joué de
musique
il fallait le même jour à supporter du
taux tout ce qu'on avait connu à vent
tourner et mémoire nos idées en bas donc
ça a été quasiment
mais le lendemain 5 ou 6 ans et plus
marquants et jetées chaque puck
je vous ai donné des exemples de la
sainte alliance ou le succès de la
nouvelle et je vous donne des exemples
où tout était réuni pour le succès et le
personnel pour tâter un exemple hyper
connu ses côtés dans les années soixante
sept ans 80 conakry était la plus grosse
société dont 200 milles en paille et le
livre ne sied pas en lui la photographie
et le sel de cette vendeuse en
argentique doubler des films les flux
photographique argentique ce qui est
pire eu beaucoup de gens simples c'est
que en 78 tu connais personne une maison
japonaise avait inventé l'appareil
numérique un appareil photo numérique il
est là bas 0 1 millions de pixels 20
secondes enfin passer une photo sur la
tête qu'à 7 bis et 20 secondes
mais même l'idée dès jeudi et elle l'a
été chez kodak ayant raté cinq ans plus
tard saulnier calonne envahissent le
marché avec un appareil mais pourquoi
est ce qu'ils vont voter
donc j'ai déniché des sites et des bleus
de tourner deux choses tout redon
qu'est-ce qui a fait que celle qu'ils
ont raté cette invention au point
d'éclater phaïdon 2010
disparu en 2012 qu'est ce qui a fait le
voleur leur défaite c'est simplement le
fait que à l'époque de l'alcool et de
surveiller tous les ingénieurs qui
étaient là étaient des chemises la
photographie était tourné autour de la
chimie
c'est un processus chimique a signé un
film argentique c'était de la chimie et
qu'il fallait passer son temps à toutes
vos ingénieurs électroniciens et nos
machines à l'autre et sambre apple vous
êtes jusqu'au maire de la seyne
contraire ils sont reconnus comme
innovatif alors qu'il n'aurait misé un
peu d'avancé ordinateurs achetés restent
à inventer la tablette apple n'a pas
inventé la souris apple n'a pas inventé
les interfaces graphiques
vous pouvez vérifier apple n'a pas
inventé la collègue dewan j'en ai une
âme en paix mais ça existe depuis trois
garçons ça s'achète en corée pour moins
cher et ça marche
de tout temps il ya eu un problème avec
la recherche que j'ai que j'ai évité
pour t'éviter parler c'est le
financement mais ça existe et 2002 les
deux dernières années mais ça devient de
plus en plus critique de ces joutes
alors pour éviter ça les ingénieurs et
ceux qui financent la recherche force
des gens comme nous à travailler sur 22
von matt williams a plus essayé de
définir les tendances du tube en
regardant la société en regardant il
existe d'autres techniques dans tous les
domaines la chimie les sciences sociales
la physique le la microélectronique et
c'est un voilà que tout ce qui se
passait sur base de sa essayé de
construire au demain pour le futur et
j'ai quelques dessins qui est juste il
le souhaite vivement une seconde
les quelques informations les aquarelles
de ce trouble niveau elles font portal
en fait dieu que c'est simple de même
que le travail tous les systèmes de nous
avons nous vaquons manix wong élections
2021 tout le monde se dirige la csc
domaines de recherche
les interfaces seront adaptés pour
s'adapter rapidement aux bons textes
communs terminé à vos besoins les
interfaces seront plus de plus en plus
insistants personnalisé en assistance
aux assistants du pouvoir vous aider
dans vos impôts
retrouvez de l'information à tout moment
où que vous soyez à voir même plaisir
temps de lui demander de danse de
l'examen les systèmes informatiques
contrairement à google seront capables
de trouver l'information dont vous avez
besoin sans devoir chercher
l'information recherche active de
l'information tout ça est prévue pour
2022 les robots sociaux les recours
seront là en 2004 pourront communiquer
gaz humaines pour communiquer entre eux
on a un beau demain jusqu'en 2024
retraité des sciences sociales
électronique la promo steam et ses
descentes punitives pour développer vos
et le cahier celui qui me tient le plus
à coeur c'est les systèmes qui vont se
construit autour des réseaux sociaux
mais bwin et les gens collaborer et on
revient synonyme de départ et j'ai les
gens être une mort plus créative plus
souvent en travaillant en cours et je
parle dans une sur l'ordinateur ne sera
plus votre compagnon mais il sera plutôt
un médiateur au centre de la
communication et qui est grand chacun
d'entre nous à collaborer et à
l'accusateur je vais m'arrêter là juste
avec une belle conclusion c'est parce
que vous avez un peu le le la ligne
rouge ce que j'ai essayé de faire passer
comme message
mais en gros succès il ya deux mille ans
il ya encore 200 ans
oui en corse en tout je crois que
beaucoup les découvertes pour les dévier
one-77 tendance de découverte pas à le à
zain porte un nom que j'ai toujours
difficile à maintenir
ils essaient de le mentionner cela c'est
pour dissiper sérendipité lections
sérendipité vous pouvez gagner un
dictionnaire c'est
que le phénomène de découverte par
hasard ou pactes et aujourd'hui je crois
qu'on est de plus en plus contraint avec
les méthodes de financement à on ne peut
plus se permettre on se trace des
chemins de recherche ce qui est bien ça
accélère l'innovation ou ce que l'on
croyait que l'innovation souvent dans le
cas du peuple et d'innovation cette
amélioration sur des innovations
précédentes et je crois que ça risque de
ce fait sur le long terme au prix de
l'image
merci pour votre aide